we are getting breaking headlines now
from Morgan Stanley coming out earnings
per share dat 47 cents that's a little
bit below estimates which which had it
at 49 yeah for the fourth quarter net
revenue coming in at one point zero four
billion dollars Morgan Stanley says they
are seeing fourth quarter well yeah it
looks a little it looks a little bit
weaker essentially it appears to me that
the story once again is this week
trading revenue for more let's bring in
allison williams from bloomberg
intelligence Alice I know this is a bit
unfair to do for you because you don't
have the net don't have the terminal
right in front of you but but what does
that look like to you 47 cents earnings
per share does that sort of fit the
story we've seen from the big banks
across the street well it looks like the
the operating number was lighter than
that forty cents is what I'm saying I'm
not sure if that is okay and you know
keep in mind you want to X out
evaluation gains and there's also quite
there's probably a legal charge we've
seen that at several of the banks this
quarter right I think for Morgan stamp
you know for most of the banks what
we've seen is the fixed income coming in
weaker than expected it equities better
for Morgan Stanley they have sort of a
unique commodities business it tends to
be a lot lumpier than some of the other
companies so if there's a big Delta in
the earnings my guess is that's that's
where I'd be looking and there was a
revision down in December right after
they said that they were gonna you know
change compensation be more in line with
with other finance company well they
came out and said that they were going
to be taking sort of an extra cost in
the quarter we're seeing that kind of I
think come across now they elevated
compensation expense by 1.1 billion they
had said 1.2 and really what they're
doing there is moving more from I think
they had said they were out eighty
percent deferred on average for bonus
bonuses and they're going to a
50-percent ratio and what that really
means is as you pay your employees more
in cash today your expenses are higher
today but what's helpful about that is
it removes your flexibility in future
years because you have less costs coming
in in future years when you take the
cost today and differ less where do you
think we are sort of in awe in the
multi-billion dollar fines are we
finally in the night
in here for the u.s. bags I think we're
a Thor ninth-inning and if you look at
what what the investment banks I think
are trying to do this quarter or in the
next several weeks is really to try to
accrue as much expense as they can into
2014 to really get that behind them and
they have to do a few more weeks we've
been hoping to get some settlements just
to get some closure on some of those
four years now the story has been
cost-cutting in cost-cutting but a lot
of people aren't telling us now that
basically all James Gorman and Jamie
Dimon can do is cut into bone is there
any more fat to take out here or perhaps
are we going to see job losses I think
as long as you see revenue pressure
you're going to see a focus on costs
it's just it's just the way that the
math is going to work and I think you
can't look broadly I think you have to
look at individual businesses and what's
happening so in certain businesses you
may be starting to get close to cutting
into bone but in other businesses where
there is still opportunity for
technology to improve efficiency perhaps
there's more opportunity to bring the
cost down when you look at the overall
the we know the week training we've seen
for the fourth quarter overall for all
the big banks do you think that this is
a direct result of dodd-frank regulation
well I think they're there are some
things that are a direct result of
dodd-frank regulation right so we have
we have banks that are have to scale
back from certain businesses and the
bigger impact has really been on the
prof overall profitability of the firm
so bags hold more capital your return on
that capital just mathematically is
going to decline